um so
again thank you so much for the
wonderful introduction michael
and thank you everyone for having me
here i know it's a tricky time for a lot
of people at the moment
um with covid and so on um so i'm really
grateful to have you all join my talk
and i look forward to meeting many of
you and i'm happy to answer any
questions or follow up individually as
well
and i'm really excited to share my work
so just to tell you a little bit about
myself for those of you just joining in
i'm an assistant cs professor at
virginia tech starting this coming fall
but again as michael
um so kindly introduced i decided to
spend some time as a postdoc here at
stanford computer science
as part of the nlp group and for my
current work at stanford
i'm focusing on using nlp and statistics
to examine linguistic patterns related
to escalation
in police interactions captured through
body-worn cameras
and for this project you know i work
with wonderful people such as uh dan
jurassic from the cs
and jennifer eberhard from the psych
department here at stanford
for today's talk however i'm going to be
focusing on my earlier work at uci where
i recently finished my phd just last
year
so i'll be excited to jump right in
if you're like myself or my friends you
know
um these days watching the news can be
difficult
and talking about it online even harder
especially when it's about politics or
social issues
and in fact uh we are like most people
here living in the us
according to a survey conducted earlier
just last year
you know almost half of americans have
stopped talking about news related to
politics with other people
and what's really interesting is that
adults who are more engaged with
political news
are more likely to have stopped
discussing social or political issues
with others
and this is a real problem because if we
look back at history
and how most democratic nations have
evolved you know people's ability to
engage in democratic discourse
or the ability to access and interpret
factual information
and critically reflect and discuss
important social issues
enables people to find common ground
with each other
despite having social or political
differences
and this is crucial for democracies to
function properly
you know it's what keeps governments
accountable and brings society together
however we all know that this is a real
challenge today
about 67 percent of americans report to
feeling confused
about basic facts around current events
while 70 percent report to having seen
political news that seems completely
made up
and furthermore we have political
extremism making it harder than ever for
people to talk to each other about
important social topics and issues and
on top of this
thanks to technology the way we access
interpret and discuss information with
others have
significantly changed over the years
from watching televised news broadcast
typically in the evening
more people now are coming across news
whenever
and wherever in the course of doing
something else
another example is the display of
information in newspapers
professional editors carefully curated
content by category of topic and length
whereas today people can easily come
across new
content sandwiched between
advertisements
videos or memes furthermore while
discourse
primarily occurred through face-to-face
interactions in the past
today online conversations around
current events are
often with strangers known only perhaps
by username
or profile picture in a thread of
thousands of other commenters and in
fact on social media
there are many design features that are
increasingly characterizing the
conditions of how people come across
and talk about current events take for
example the infinity scrolling of
content on news feeds
where attention is calibrated in
microseconds
or hashtags that amplify the visibility
of popular or trending social topics
and we also have affective comments or
emotive buttons
that induce us to emotionally react to
news content
or even just observe how others do so
so clearly the conditions in which
modern political discourse occurs have
changed significantly
and without really understanding how
these changes are affecting the way we
perceive
and talk about important social and
political issues
online it will be impossible to improve
the online environment
as an avenue for democratic discourse so
what can we do
you know as hci researchers we
understand that the design of online
spaces
affects how people engage with others
and interpret content
in a similar vein in political
communication researchers have
shown that the digital public sphere or
the conditions in which online discourse
occurs
is said to be a key determinant of
discourse quality
and as someone who kind of sits at the
intersection between hci
political communication it's hard not to
notice the strong interconnected link
between these two fields
now for example the conditions in which
online discourse occurs
are made up of the various online design
features that i've previously shown such
as hashtags affective comments emotive
buttons and so on
in other words the design of online
spaces shapes the conditions in which
online discourse occurs
second discourse quality is something
that we understand
through how people talk with others and
interpret content
so putting these two statements together
in other words what both fields are
saying is that the design of online
environments affects
discourse quality but how
this is precisely the question my
research focuses on
as a scholar and researcher my work
bridge is the field of hci and political
communication
through which i examine and demonstrate
how the current design of online
environments
shape the quality of online democratic
discourse at scale
and in doing so i take two approaches
you know first
i identify linguistic factors related to
discourse quality
for which i often use nlp machine
learning
statistics as well as qualitative
content analyses
and second i demonstrate at scale
through empirical methods
the direct impact of online design
features on linguistic
behavior through large-scale surveys and
experimental design
and so far using these approaches i've
examined how online design
impacts the nature of discussion on race
class and issues related to gender
and and and in today's talk i'm going to
demonstrate how political hashtags
as a common online design character
affect the quality of online discourse
around current events
using these two approaches you know
first
i'm going to show you how linguistic
factors related to discourse quality
what words we use how we use it
contribute to the divide in online
conversations around political hashtags
and second i'll demonstrate how the
presence
versus absence of political hashtags and
social media news articles
directly shapes the quality of discourse
around social topics
related to race and gender issues
so hashtags related to social issues or
political hashtags
are pretty much an inseparable part of
online discussions around current events
in fact you know designers and engineers
have turned to political hashtags
to increase participation in online
discussion around social issues
typically by building systems that
classify rank and attach the top most
popular hashtags to articles
based on the frequency of hashtags
appearing in social media conversations
in a similar vein journalists are also
using political hashtags as shown here
to increase readership and to
contextualize reporting
especially on social topics and this
practice is particularly salient on
social media
where news companies incorporate
hashtags in the headlines
or the text part of the social media
article in these short digestible
previews
and for this tactic to be effective it's
pretty common for news writers
to capitalize on political hashtags that
are known to have gone viral
and thus have brought resonance with
current and potential readership
and according to columbia journalism
review such practice is perceived as a
good way to introduce a story or
perspective
into the mainstream news cycle and a way
to figure out
what the public wants to discuss and
learn more about
you know researchers too for the most
part have generally taken a
positive view of how political hashtags
shape online discourse
emphasizing that political hashtags
inform debate
challenge public perceptions around
contested topics
and enable personal storytelling across
discursive networks
so engineers are using them journalists
and news companies are using them
and researchers and scholars for the
most part think political hashtags have
a
positive influence on online public
discourse
then why are we extremely divided
across issues embodied by political
hashtags
for example one year after the metoo
movement
reports now show that people's opinions
have shifted more
negatively against me to survivors and
according to polls
people are more divided on issues
surrounding sexual harassment
with the divide running primarily along
partisan lines
likewise the majority of americans have
an unfavorable view of black lives
matter
several years after it first came to
national prominence
and again in light in light of uh recent
events uh just last year
um reactions to the black lives matter
hashtags have become
even more complicated so again why are
people becoming increasingly
polarized around important and
substantive social issues
embodied by political hashtags to answer
this question
and given my interest in discourse
behavior i first turned to
actual facebook comments surrounding me
too articles published by three very
politically distinct news outlets
to demonstrate how linguistic behavior
contributes to this divide and
perspectives around political hashtags
and here i focused on linguistic style
and affect
you know how people talk about issues
related to the metoo hashtag
what kind of words they persistently
used how they used it
as well as the kind of topics they
focused on
and finally i examined some of the
biases or framing effects
that emerged from their linguistic
behavior
so from the three facebook news pages i
first identified all articles
headlined with me too in the news post
and from here i'm going to refer to news
articles
published on facebook as news posts and
i analyzed
all the comments including replies on
each article and here are the key
differences i found
first comments from the far left and
alt-right news sites
exhibited significantly greater use of
profanity and words related to anger and
sex
compared to those from the mainstream
outlet for example
outright comments contain nearly three
times the proportion of sexual words and
five times the proportion of swear words
compared to the new york times comments
far left comments contain nearly twice
the proportion of such words compared to
the comments from the mainstream outlet
and such difference in linguistic style
especially in terms of
negative affect is really important to
take into consideration
because research shows that when people
engage in heuristic processing
of political information on social media
negative emotional words
induce more negative conclusions on
what's being discussed
what this means is that if you have a
flood of social media news comments
charged with negative affect this can
create a strong negativity bias towards
the discussion topic
and this is exactly what was shown in
the data
these are tfidf results based on the
comments from the
alt right and far left articles on me
too and here i'm showing you the list of
keywords
in the descending order of tf idf weight
which i used as a proxy to examine
topical importance
across commenters and as you can see
both breitbart and democracy now
commenters are
topically focused on sex with frequent
references to body parts
and not only were these commenters
pretty similar in the
kind of topics they focused on but they
were very similar in how they discuss
these topics
across breitbart comments um sex had the
highest tfidf weight
which means that it was a major topic
that was often brought up
and in these comments people often
brought in strong prior beliefs
or assumptions around the legitimate
legitimacy of victim status and sexual
encounters
which is why the word sex occurs a lot
for example
uh one commenter says so you sleep
around and then
20 or 30 years later decide that you
were harassed or made to have sex
did any claim rape did they have a gun
or knife held to their throats
how does one claim they were forced to
have sex i'd just like to know
across the far left comments people are
focused on race denoted in this key word
color
um and these commenters often argued
over
which race or class should be included
or
excluded in the metoo narrative as you
can see in the following comment
yes women of color and working-class
women
are especially vulnerable but me too is
primarily with regard to upper-class
white women
so these are some distinct linguistic
patterns showing
you know what words people persistently
use how they use it
what kind of topics they focus on in
discussion of me too across
public politically different facebook
news sources
and it got me thinking what kind of
framing effects can emerge from such
conversational behavior
and framing effect is a form of
cognitive bias in which
people react to a given choice in
different ways depending on how the
choice is presented
in social linguistic research there is a
similar idea
expressed by firth who argues
understanding how a word is
characterized by its nearby words can
reveal
key linguistic context in which it is
discussed
uh so based on this premise i used war
to vek
which is a simple neural network model
to quantify the semantic proximity
uh between the word meet to and nearby
words that co-occur with it
to understand the potential framing
around how metoo is discussed
and i built three embedding models using
the corpus of commons from the three new
sources
and found some key differences uh here
i'm showing the top 25 word embedding
tokens
most similar to the word metoo based on
cosine similarity values
and the cosine values here are uh
basically the
similarity of angles between each
vectorized token
and the word metoo uh ranging from one
denoting that they're identical to
negative one
uh meaning that they're kind of uh
absolute polar opposites
and as you can see among the new york
times facebook news comments
v2 is semantically closest with tokens
such as
hashtag group campaign you know words
that are intuitively characterizing me
too as an online social movement or a
hashtag campaign
for breitbart me too had strong semantic
associations
with and always whereas for the
far left comments me too was
semantically closest with words
associated with
social economic status such as fame
money famous rich and perhaps even
hollywood
so taking these embedding results i
conducted i conducted a qualitative
analysis
of all the comments that included these
top embedding tokens
and found that there was a strong
in-group versus out-group dynamics
in rhetorical behavior that kind of
reinforced biases around how michi was
framed and discussed
for example breitbart comments portray
me to participants
as and who always have
manipulative sex and
to advance their careers exhibiting a
form of outgroup derogation as shown in
this quote
because metoo is about liars looking for
profit and control
it's always the quote-unquote powerful
male say name
and as shown in this example counters
often used
absolutist expressions such as always
and the word always is a really
interesting word in political dialogue
because it's a form of rhetoric when
used often and persistently
is harmful for constructive discourse
around moral and political issues
that need to bridge a wide spectrum of
opinions and perspectives
but throughout my analyses i found that
alt-right commenters
consistently use such expressions when
describing those
associated with the metoo movement
all left commenters on the other hand
exhibited strong
in-group favoritism based on race and
socio-economic status
commenters frequently argued over how
women of color or
low income deserved more attention
within the metoo movement
or that rich and famous women were
unfairly hijacking the metoo narrative
from those who are more racially
um and socioeconomically privileged you
know for example
um uh uh compter from
the far left um uh
news source reads the brutal gang rape
of racy taylor
is not comparable to the alleged sexual
assaults that rich white women
oftentimes previously endured for fame
and money
are fighting for in their new media
movements
and as shown you know far left
communists are make are making these
blanket statements around which group
deserves more empathy
while we have alt-right commenters uh
making sweeping assumptions about
the definition of sexual harassment or
the character of those who
are coming forth about their experience
using the metoo hashtag
you know in other words what we're
seeing from this work is
a lot of linguistic behavior based on
generalized expressions
that promote dominant viewpoints uh
within the discussion circle
while marginalizing minority
perspectives and again
this is harmful for democratic discourse
because it discourages
empathy and sharing which ultimately
lowers the
chance to find a commonality through
shared experiences as people
despite having different political views
so by looking at linguistic factors
related to discourse quality
uh clearly we can see that you know
people's linguistic behavior
what words they use how they use it what
topics they focus on is reaffirming
divisions and perspectives
around how political hashtags are
consumed and understood
but this could be just part of the
picture
you know what if political hashtags
themselves were part of the problem
you know to find out i conducted an
online experiment
to examine whether and how the presence
versus
absence of political hashtags in news
post shaped audience reaction
in the previous project i examined
discussion quality across
three politically distinct news sources
under one design condition
which was social media news posts with
hashtags
in the second part of this talk i'm
going to talk about an experiment in
which i vary the design condition
by examining both the presence and
absence of political hashtags in news
posts while
keeping the media bias of the new source
constant
so using qualtrics i designed an
experimental survey
in which i randomly show each
participant a news post
either containing or excluding political
hashtags in the headline and the text
portion of the news post
the hashtag condition on the left as you
can see here was actually
the version published by npr and for the
control condition on the right i
excluded the hashtag in the post text
as well as a phrase me to prompts in the
headline
and for the experiment we used ford news
post topically focused on me too
and four on black lives matter giving us
a total of eight news articles
originally published on the new york
times and npr facebook pages
and the selection of the articles was
primarily based on
whether the intended message of the
article could be best preserved
with just minimal modification of the
headline and the text portion of the
news post
regardless of whether there was a
hashtag or not
so for each news post there was a
control and a hashtag
version as shown here but we wanted to
take this a step further and add a
second experimental factor
to reflect the reality of social media
news articles that often contain
um affective positive negative comments
so i decided to add positive
negative comments as a second factor uh
giving us a two by three factorial
design
and this resulted in a total of 48 news
posts
one of which was randomly shown in the
survey system
uh to the survey participant who
answered questions
um and left a comment and reaction to
the one news post they saw in the survey
so through this experiment i wanted to
find out
whether and how the presence of
political hashtags and news posts
affected the way people perceive news
contents specifically in terms of both
positive negative reactions
for positive reaction i asked whether
participants found the topic of the news
post
was socially important and whether they
wanted to know more about social issues
pertaining to the news post
and in terms of negative reaction i
asked participants whether they found
the news post partisan
and whether they perceive the news
content to be controversial
and to understand these positive and
negative reactions as dependent outcomes
we ask people to respond to each
corresponding statements as shown here
using a 5.5 point agreement scale
and this is what we found when hashtags
are included in news posts
people perceive the news topic to be
significantly less socially important
and are less motivated to know more
about social issues
related to the news content and in terms
of negative reaction
people find news posts more partisan
when political hashtags are included
and also find the news topic more
controversial
and this got me thinking uh since prior
research
repeatedly shows that hyper partisanship
is
linked with less motivation to engage
with social issues
and that the quality of democracy is
partly the extent to which people are
engaged with politics through social
issues
i wanted to further examine whether this
negative perception
associated with political hashtags was a
mechanism
that drives that explains decreased
motivation for
positive engagement around hashtag news
content
hence i conducted a path analysis which
showed that indeed
when political hashtags are included in
news posts
participants find the hashtag news
content more partisan
but this is also the reason why people
perceive the news topic to be less
socially important
as well as why they are less motivated
less motivated to know more about social
issues
related to the news post similarly
political hashtags and news posts which
heightens people's perception that the
news topic is controversial
deters people from wanting to know more
about social issues
related to the news content and in fact
it's not just the politically
conservative but also the politically
moderate participants
who have strong partisan reactions to
news content with political hashtags
using kernel density estimate i
visualize the distribution of responses
towards the following statement
the partisan undertone of this news post
is obvious
across three political groups
and the distribution of responses among
those who identified and surveyed
as extremely liberal for both the
hashtag and the control groups
are left skewed meaning in general these
folks tend to regard news posts about
gender and racial topics from our
experiment
less partisan regardless of hashtag
presence
by contrast for the extremely
conservative
the distributions are more right skewed
meaning that these participants perceive
news content
with or without hashtags as politically
biased
so you can imagine um who did the
political hashtags really affect in
terms of
partisan reactions towards news content
it was the participants who identified
themselves as politically moderate
and among these politically moderate
participants those who saw news posts
with hashtags
perceive news posts as more partisan
than those shown news posts without the
hashtags
um as illustrated in the shaded gap
between the blue and red distributions
here
and in fact this difference um and
partisan reaction between the control
and the hashtag groups
among the politically moderate uh was
significant
uh with the medium effect size so
uh political hashtags clearly affect how
people perceive news content
both positively and negatively and in
terms of
partisan reaction hashtags particularly
affect
those who consider consider themselves
politically moderate
now let's take a look at how political
hashtags affect the way people talk
uh specifically um i want to show you
how political hashtags shape the
language people use in their comments
in reaction to news posts that they saw
in the survey
first when hashtags were included in
news posts
people use significantly more words
associated with anger
fear and disgust and again if you recall
from my earlier study
we know that linguistic style and affect
especially negative affect
can generate a strong negativity bias
around what's being discussed
furthermore when hashtags were included
people also used more language
predominantly focused on the hashtag
itself drowning out any reference to the
main subject matter of the news post
for example what i'm showing you here
are the keywords
listed in the descending order of pmi or
pointwise mutual information scores
which i used as a proxy to measure
topical focus
and what you're seeing here is that when
the black lives matter hashtags are
included in news posts
people tend to use language that is
clearly focused on the hashtag itself
by contrast those in the control group
who saw the same
exact news article again identical news
articles but without the black lives
matter hashtag
use language that are topically focused
on the actual subject matter of the news
content
and let me show you some examples of
what these comments from the survey
respondents actually looked like
here these are identical news posts one
version containing the hashtag
based on the original news post and one
that has been modified to exclude the
hashtag on the right
and going forth i'm going to show you
some results from
the content analyses of the comments
written by politically moderate
participants from both the control and
the hashtag groups
at first in the hashtag group
participants repeatedly mentioned the
hashtag
without substantially engaging with
relevant social issues
as shown in this example and when such
discussion behavior is replicated on
social media
this can amplify how much one is exposed
to a constant
yet substance-wise empty reiteration
and assessment of the hashtag resulting
in linguistic behavior focused on the
politics of the hashtag
as shown here by contrast
comments from the control group showed
that ironically
the absence of the hashtags actually
promoted the core ideas and values of
the hashtag
that that was originally meant to
represent for example a commenter in the
control group
who saw the news article without the
metoo hashtag recognizes the importance
of giving platform and
voice um to survivors of sexual
harassment on social media
and keeping track of these instances
without them going unheard
which is the essence of what metoo
intended to represent
and such reactions from the control
group are really different
from the commenters from the hashtag
group who often
question the credibility of the news
content
for example by referring to the news
article statistics
as a load of crap or that the figures on
the news
on the topic has been inflated
and as a result leading them to think
that the article was fake
by contrast reactions from the control
group
were much more nuanced and subdued um
for example commenters remarked my first
reaction
is that these numbers are really high or
i find the information
non-biased frankly these numbers seem
low to me
another politically moderate commentary
the control group remark
i suspect that the numbers for men may
be lower due to the stigma that men
reporting sexual assault would be viewed
as weak
so as you can see you know respondents
from both the hashtag and the control
groups
are reacting to the same details shown
in the news post
however the interpretation as well as
the language used to interpret the
content are vastly different
in fact commenters from the hashtag
group use more emotionally extreme
expressions
for example even those who seem to be in
favor of the hashtag movement
use pretty aggressive language to convey
support for the movement
another prominent difference which was
uh really interesting to see in the
analysis
was the use of first person perspective
and how people grounded their arguments
for example this is a news post that
originally included the black lives
matter hashtag
and here's the version where we removed
it and when the hashtag was removed
people often preface their arguments in
the first person
and these comments that i'm about to
show you are redacted for the purposes
of this presentation i think is these
days should be
you know i think that the main problem i
think it makes some good points
i'm a firm believer that i think that
discussing
and to me uh this is really fascinating
rhetorical behavior
because in political communication the
use of first-person perspective and
dialogue
is pretty significant because it
rhetorically anchors a discourse to the
present moment of conversation
and it signals reflection of personal
values into the reasoning behind one's
words
and is an indication of cognitive
processing as well as
sense of authenticity which are factors
that are known to contribute
to constructive social discussion
behavior
contrast this with why don't all lives
matter
black lives absolutely matter black
lives matter is a crucial topic
black lives matter so do white lives
asian lives hispanic lives and as you
can see here
the language in these comments is less
reflective
less personal and less open to
difference and instead
the majority of comments are strong duck
letter declarative statements that
repetitively pivot around the black
lives matter hashtag
which leaves no room for conversation uh
with people who might share different
perspectives
i remember in the first study i told you
when we repeat repetitively process a
flood of negative uh
content on social media where people
process things through
mental shortcuts it creates a negativity
bias
and turns people off and
our research statistically confirms this
you know people who use
facebook more often several times a day
are significantly more turned off by
these hashtags compared to those who are
on facebook once a week
in other words repeated exposure to
political hashtags
are turning people off as expressed by
this one participant who uses facebook
several times a day
and was shown a news post containing a
hashtag
honestly social media is generating
something akin to false positivity
or inflated enthusiasm i am so sick of
this i am very liberal i'm not racist or
anything
but it's just too much if i see another
post on the internet about someone being
a strong woman
i'm gonna lose my mind no one is
benefiting from this we are not really
more informed
there's less information and more of the
same opinions on the same side
expressed in this reaction you know
false positivity inflated enthusiasm
not feeling more informed and being
turned off by the news
is pretty much the sentiment that echoes
the reality of what most americans are
feeling and experiencing in terms of
online news consumption and political
discourse
as i've mentioned in the very beginning
of this talk and what's contributing to
this reaction is something
seemingly simple yet pervasive
as a political hashtag this is why we
need to examine
the quality of online discourse in
relation to online design features
and i make two arguments as to how we
can do so you know first
when we think about designing for better
online discourse we need to take
passive consumers or non-users into
consideration
and second we need to take not just
functional but also
intertextual aspects of design and i'll
break down what these two things mean
first remember how i told you that
scholars have generally taken a positive
view of how political hashtags
shape the online public sphere while
implicit in these studies
is the assumption that hashtag media is
received in a manner
aligned with the goals of the community
using the hashtags
to promote or debate a particular social
issue in the first place
however nearly all prior literature have
focused on what i call hashtag producers
or those who explicitly use hashtags and
posting online content
and this is most likely because of the
common process of
collecting data through api filtering of
tweets or comments
that includes specific hashtags which
makes pi
research to focus predominantly on
hashtag producers
and right now most research using social
media data
to understand the nature of
conversations or discourse quality
around social topics
are based on such methods and i want to
argue that we need to rethink
and evaluate how our methodological
approaches are kind of limiting the way
we understand online discourse
and as a first step as shown in my work
we need to take
non-users or passive content consumers
into consideration
because as demonstrated in my findings
non-users or
those who are passively exposed to
hashtag content
may not actually perceive or engage in
similar ways to the hashtag producers
and this is important especially
because to affect change in social
discourse and public knowledge around
political issues
it's important that we are able to
mobilize a broader audience
that goes beyond passionate enthusiasts
in other words
impact needs to spread beyond those
initially aligned with the movement
however my work shows that politically
moderate respondents
you know people in the middle are turned
off by political hashtags
and in fact contrary to prior literature
my finding shows that in the long run
uh political hashtags may impede
critical conversations around social
topics
especially around social media news
content which are and will continue to
be
important public spheres of discourse
this brings me to my second point to
design for better online discourse
we need to take not just functional but
also intertextual aspects of design into
consideration
earlier i talked about engineers who
build systems using political hashtags
as design features to increase
participation and discussion quality
well most of these engineers are
predominantly focused on
the functional aspects of hashtags which
you know enable searchability
uh based on the frequency in which
hashtags appear across online
conversations
which in other words are again putting
an emphasis on hashtag producers
and overlooking non-users or passive
content consumers
furthermore the sole emphasis on
functional aspects of design
runs the risk of overlooking the
intertextual nature of design features
related to online discourse
and let me explain what this means
intertextuality is a notion that text
attains its meaning
in relation to other texts and i'll
explain to you what this means using
political hashtags
as an example when a political hashtag
becomes popular or is in the process of
becoming popular
the hashtag will be used in various ways
through the written text of
millions of networked users and in that
process
because any kind of utterance including
ones that contain hashtags
is by nature dialogic which means that a
word's meaning and power
depends on what has been previously said
about it the hashtag evolves
and gains meaning in relation to other
texts depending on
how it has been used and what has been
said about it
and this intertextuality allows hashtags
to become
charged with an additional semiotic pool
as we have seen in my work
and this is why when designing for
better online discourse we need to think
about the intertextual aspects of them
of online design features
so uh as a recap we're facing this
problem where
people's motivation and ability to
engage in online discourse
is negatively affected with the rise of
fake news
misinformation and political extremism
at the same time
we also face a challenge where the
conditions of online discourse
have been significantly changing over
the years
yet so far the conventional approach to
understanding the nature of online
discourse
has focused on content producers while
the connection between
online design and discourse quality has
yet to be explored with depth
to this end my work empirically examines
the relationship between online design
and discourse quality through various
mixed methods
and take non-users and passive content
consumers into consideration
in doing so my goal is to provide a
renewed understanding around how common
online design features
shape discourse quality at scale and by
deriving empirical insights
i aim to contribute to the theoretical
implication
of online deliberation and design
research by bridging the field of hci
and political communication both through
methodological practice and theory
and finally the way i see my research
having impact is by informing better
design and engineering practices
for industry partners that operate our
social platforms
um and a goal here is to really take my
findings as a
conversation starter to build a serious
dialogue
not just with tech companies but also
with journalists
policy makers and activists and hence i
envision my work
to open up broader applications to other
topical domains
which i can talk about in my future work
if i have time
um
by the way i'm recruiting phd students
uh for my lab at virginia tech so if
you're interested
or know berlin students please send them
my way
so i'll go through this very quickly so
as you can see from my work
i'm someone who believes that with
better understanding of online design
we can increase our chances of improving
the quality of online discourse
you know how we access interpret and
talk about information with other people
and first my immediate line of research
focuses on
understanding and improving online
discourse quality at scale
and here i'm really interested in
identifying linguistic markers around
affective psychological and rhetorical
patterns of speech that can
better inform how we understand good
versus bad online discourse
and the motivation here is based on the
fact that in order to improve discourse
quality
we need to first be able to distinguish
apart what constitutes
factual uh constructive perspective
taking from
you know toxic divisive and misinforming
linguistic behavior
but we need to do this in relation to
online design
and this will be done through
application of nlp deep learning
uh on a repository of data collected
through large-scale experiments
and for this part of the work i'm really
looking to collaborate with industry
partners
especially on their efforts to reduce
toxicity on their platforms
skip and second i'm really excited to
examine um
how audio visual cues you know such as
images
tone voice facial expressions captured
in various sources of data from both on
and offline interactions
can be used to better understand how
people talk to each other in various
contexts
hence i'm looking forward to not only
expanding the domain of interactions i'm
examining
but also expanding into the different
methodologies and approaches
in which audio visual cues can be
analyzed in combination with
with text and here the goal is to
understand
how the various audio visual design cues
are not only shaping the nature of
uh online interactions but how they
might be perhaps linked with
practical real-life consequences you
know from election results to
fundraising impact
job employment and so on uh and it is in
addition i will explore the different
ways we can
leverage audio visual cues and textual
data together
to better understand and improve the way
we talk to each other
in offline context such as the work that
i'm currently doing
looking at interactions captured through
video footages of
officers and drivers and traffic stops
so again i'm looking for creative ways
to partner up with
industry and academic collaborators and
look forward to working with bright
students
so please don't hesitate to reach out to
me
yeah so this is end of my talk i'm so
glad i'm
right under the time limit uh you've
been a fantastic audience
and i'm very happy to take questions
all right thank you so much um so
panelists feel free to go ahead and just
unmute yourselves and ask questions
in the meantime i just sent out a link
to all the students if you'd like to
submit
q a to the to the link we have a bunch
of good questions already i'll
start with one or two of those and then
we'll flip over to the panel
uh so one question was asking
you found that conservatives found the
articles about black lives matter and me
too to be partisan
regardless of hashtags and that
moderates found them more partisan when
the
hashtags were present and they pointed
out that
black lives matter and me too could um
they felt that they could generally be
considered to be
sort of liberally oriented topics or
hashtags and they were wondering whether
there would be similar results for
conservative hashtags
yeah so me too and black lives matter
are generally regarded as uh hashtags
pertaining to
a liberal political perspective and
that's why we wanted to include
uh hashtags uh that resonated um
more strongly with uh the conservative
political views such as
you know a um a2 references gun rights
uh second amendment um and other
uh conservative political hashtags
unfortunately
for this study we were limited in the
sense that we were looking for hashtags
that were
used by mainstream media
repetitively to frame the news
content and most of the conservative
hashtags
were not in mainstream news sources and
the headlines
and a lot of these conservative hashtags
tended to focus on specific people
you know donald trump or um hillary
or hillary clinton um and so forth so it
really didn't
capture the essence of um the hashtag's
role
in framing these content so that's why
we couldn't look at
more of the political politically
conservative hashtags but that's a good
point
yeah one also i was wondering
if you have thoughts about how to go
about convincing the stakeholders like
at the platforms for example to realign
their efforts
toward quality political discourse over
just increased participation
and she points out that hashtags often
serve a purpose for the platform's
monetary or user data goals that's hard
to push back on
so what do we do what are we to do about
this absolutely that
is such a salient point and
um talking to industry researchers from
facebook and twitter
um you know there there is a conflict of
interest in terms of how
the platform operates um to generate
revenue versus
um managing the quality of conversations
that take place there
and uh you know that's that's that's a
tricky
um um that that's not in it's really not
easy to have that kind of conversation
but a starting point is to have this
discussion started
and increase awareness around how
hashtags are
affecting conversations aside from their
functional
uh purposes and their functional
necessity in operating
these platforms if there is a way to
leverage
um you know different design mechanisms
to
uh to give people a better awareness
about what's going on with these
trending hashtags
that would be a start and i recall from
one of the conversations i had with
um someone from twitter is perhaps we
can there could be
a way to visually indicate
the the polarity around the hashtag that
is trending
um but but i think that's
the starting point is to really have
that dialogue and increase awareness
around how hashtags can impact
how hashtags can impact conversations
um so yeah formerly at stanford now
just a member of the community um
it seemed like in your um conclusion
slide for the
real world implications you said
something to the effect of
journalists and others should consider
these results as they're figuring out
how to
word things whereas
a takeaway i got from your data was
maybe you should consider not using them
at all yeah
why is that not the conclusion where is
there some
argument for using them uh
i think so you know these hashtags
embody really important social topics
and issues and
it is a mechanism to uh facilitate
conversations
around especially difficult and
challenging topics but at the same time
as shown in my work it it does create a
strong
bias in the attitudinal reactions
towards people who come across content
that are hashtagged
and i'm not necessarily arguing to ban
all hashtags together because
depending on the way it's used there are
so many different contexts
that just can't be generalized
but when i spoke with several news
writers
they really didn't have too much
surprisingly they didn't have too much
awareness around how the hashtag can
impact the way their news content is
perceived
whereas some people are more aware of
the
attraction and volume they will get when
if they use popular hashtags
so there's a range in awareness
across journalists and news writers as
well
and i think one way to
really start having this conversation
around what the best ways to use or
perhaps not use hashtags and news
content
is to ground and increase awareness
across news writers and in the
journalism industry as well
i've been wondering what do you
do you see connections between the use
of hashtags
and then in political communication
notions of how
your positions basically get branded so
like the the terms pro-life versus
pro-choice and so on
and are they serving similar
sort of signaling roles are there
differences
you know i guess what i'm trying to
figure out is are are hashtags branding
more than their you know communication
yeah that is the argument that i'm
making
um i think while hashtags are very
powerful
um and um
the the the power that comes with
hashtags
it increases uh reach of audience
rapidly
but at the same time you are um you're
squishing all the
different complicated facets of um of a
of a complex social topic into one key
word
into a sound bite and that doesn't
facilitate
conversation in a constructive manner
especially when the topic of discussion
is is polarizing to start with and
i i agree it is um it has it has
surround similarities in the way
um key phrases are uh in political
campaigns or
political um advertisements like
keywords are thrown around
um just to increase um noise and yeah so
there is a strong similarity there
we have a ton of student questions uh
i'm
for those of you who i'm not selecting
please keep submitting in future weeks
and i will do my best to work my way
around i was wondering
uh how do you think the name of the news
outlet itself affected the thoughts
so you know is it possible that
regardless of the hashtag or
or its lack of hashtag or the comment
valence like the response would just be
the same because you know i look at
breitbart and i react a specific way uh
so
if you are pertaining to if you are
referring
uh could you can i ask you a follow-up
question is are you
uh is the question in regards to the
first half of the study or the second
half
i think they were referring to the
experimental manipulation
right right um yeah so when we were
designing this experiment we thought
about a range of new sources to select
but um and then decided to
uh narrow down to um
mainstream or what other people would
view
as more mainstream liberal mainstream
left
news sources due to to reduce the
inflammatory
um way of some
some of the headlines were using
hashtags in other
media other news find
news outlets so that's why we narrowed
it down to
the two news sources but yes that is uh
one limitation that i do take into
consideration
and we and but
to be consistent with uh the news
media bias of the news source i decided
to
uh be consistent with the choice of news
sources
uh to continue from in continuation of
the first study
as well awesome
i think we're about at time um i will
encourage those of you if you want to
engage
engage with eugenia further you know
drop her an email um
i assume they can google your name and
find your contact info absolutely
great so yeah let's all sort of thank uh
eugenia one more time
for joining us do this sort of quiet
clapping that no one can see
uh if you don't have your video on or if
you're just an attendee then you know i
don't know
send excited bits through the internet
or something
uh so thank you so much for joining us
we will end here
you